[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing a topic within the greater
wizarding world that's right i'm excited
to say that today's video is another
theory regarding the recently released
second trailer for the upcoming film
fantastic beasts the secrets of
dumbledore after a long wait and a bit
of a delay the second official trailer
for the secrets of dumbledore was
released last week and there is just so
much to go over with that in mind before
we get started on today's video if you
have yet to watch the new trailer let me
stop you right there
go check it out now i would also
encourage you to watch a few of my other
videos that break down the new trailer
to give you a bit more insight on what
we may expect from the upcoming film
including my secrets of dumbledore
trailer 2 breakdown 5 theories from the
secrets of dumbledore trailer two and
rare unseen extra footage from the
secrets of dumbledore trailer okay now
that that's taken care of let's move on
to today's topic could credence's
phoenix actually be forks for those of
you who may not know or have possibly
forgotten fawkes is the phoenix who was
albus dumbledore's most trusted animal
companion present throughout much of the
harry potter series he lived in the
headmaster's office at hogwarts and was
often seen by harry whenever he would go
speak with dumbledore
of course harry also encountered forks
on several occasions in which this
magical creature was responsible for
saving harry's life this was due to
harry's unwavering loyalty to dumbledore
and as phoenixes are incredibly loyal
animals themselves forks would come to
harry's aid just as he would come to
dumbledore's volks was faithful to
dumbledore harry was faithful to
dumbledore therefore fawkes was faithful
to harry we first see this in action in
the chamber of secrets when fawkes
rescues harry from salazar slytherin's
basilisk
not only does he attack the giant
serpent an effort to help save harry he
also delivers the very items that the
boy needs in order to defeat the
basilisk the sorting hat which reveals
the sword of gryffindor
once harrah uses the sword to kill the
basilisk forks also provides him with
tom riddle's old diary so that harry can
destroy it with one of the snake's fangs
fawkes then carries harry ron ginny and
professor gilderoy lockhart the defense
against the dark arts teacher that year
out of the chamber and heals harry's
mortal wound inflicted by the basilisk
with his tears later in the series we
see forks come to dumbledore and harry's
aid many times more from healing harry's
wounded leg after the dreadful events of
the tri-wizard tournament to all the
times he helped albus escape certain
death during duels at the ministry of
magic
all this to say that forks was an
incredibly faithful pet
but what does any of that have to do
with the secrets of dumbledore and the
new trailer
well as you may recall in the second
installment of the fantastic beast films
a small bird appears in front of
credence from amongst the wreckage after
he loses the only lead he had as to who
his birth parents were
as the movie progresses the bird
continues to be by credence's side it is
a small nondescript bird and had wagered
that most of you didn't really give it
much thought as you watch the film
however by the end of the crimes of
grindelwald we witness grindelwald
giving credence a great speech in an
effort to convince him that he's made
the right choice in siding with gelet
and his acolytes at last someone is
offering an explanation as to who
credence is
and it has everything to do with the
bird who has yet to leave his side since
it found him there is a legend in your
family the phoenix will come to any
member who is in dire need it is your
birthright my boy
as is the name i now restore to you
aurelius aurelius dumbledore grindelwald
gives this speech as the small creature
bursts into flames transforming into the
at once recognizable adult form of a
phoenix
and so it's no surprise that this
phoenix is present throughout a number
of scenes in the first and second
trailers that have been released ahead
of the latest film
true the phoenix only shows up once in
the first trailer but it flies in and
out multiple scenes in the newest
preview
most notably we see the magical bird fly
overhead of credence in some dark and
gloomy location
and then again in the middle of a street
presumably right before queens comes
face to face with his alleged brother
albus dumbledore now the very fact that
a phoenix has come to credence's side in
a time of need suggests that he truly is
a descendant of the dumbledore family
however the final trailer scene the bird
shows up in brings up several troubling
questions at least to me the scene i'm
referring to is when we see the phoenix
fly in front of not credence but albus
and this visual is paired with a warning
from dumbledore as we hear the words
things are not quite what they appear so
what could this mean exactly well as you
may have guessed from the title of this
video my foremost theory on this is that
the phoenix is in fact fawkes could it
be that despite coming to credence when
he was in need of guidance during the
second film that he changes his
allegiances to offer albus protection
or perhaps rather than changing
loyalties he simply expands his
guardianship to include another member
of the dumbledore family
in my opinion this theory would only
work if dumbledore is set to jewel
grindelwald in this scene not credence
of course the way the scene is set up i
think we're meant to believe that albus
is only dueling credence but it's
possible that the phoenix shows up to
help albus in a separate fight aside
from the one in which he's clearly
having with credence out in the streets
in any case if this phoenix is indeed
fawkes that would mean that credence is
one of three things
not a dumbledore and therefore the
bird's true loyalty light with albus a
dumbledore who proves himself unworthy
of a phoenix's protection
or a wizard who dies leaving albus as
the only dumbledore which fawkes has
pledged his allegiance to
now if none of that turns out to be true
here is one other theory that has
crossed my mind what if the phoenix is
an illusion or spell that grindelwald
has cast in order to convince credence
that he is a descendant of the
dumbledore family
to me this would be the most likely
explanation if it turns out that
credence is not a dumbledore after all
but simply griden's bare bone after all
there are many who remain skeptical that
credence is in fact a dumbledore in any
case if the phoenix is not a phoenix at
all it would make sense that grindelwald
chose a creature whose existence is
founded on fire
aside from the whole dumbledore
connection of course that is phoenix
birds are said to be immortal and will
go through life cycles which end in
bursts of flame only to be reborn in the
ashes
this event is called a burning day
in fact harry first met fawkes on one of
his burning days and was quite taken
aback by the scene in front of him
before dumbledore explained to him what
had happened and how it was all very
natural for a phoenix but i digress the
fact is phoenix birds are involved in
fire magic of a sword and as we've seen
throughout the fantastic beasts
grindelwald seems to be a fan of
elemental fire magic most obviously
you'll recall his ring of protego
diabolica one of if not the most
powerful fire spell in the wizarding
world
grindelwald cast this spell at the end
of the crimes of grindelwald using it to
invite wizards to join his cause
those who dared to cross the flames with
ill intent or a lack of loyalty were
instantly vaporized by the powerful dark
ring of fire
now in the trailer for the secrets of
dumbledore we see albus and gelet
sitting in what looks to be an abandoned
restaurant as grindelwald threatens to
burn down the world and the whole scene
erupts into flames i think the argument
for the phoenix being a trick is further
supported by the fact that in that final
scene of the crimes of grindelwald in
which kellet presents the phoenix to
credence as a piece of evidence to his
history the phoenix bursts into flames
to become a mature version of the bird i
may be incorrect but from my
understanding the phoenix only catches
fire on a burning day when it is being
reborn
not when it is maturing into a
full-fledged phoenix
so for this particular bird to erupt
into flames
right at that exact moment when
grindelwald wants to convince credence
that he's a dumbledore seems a bit too
convenient to me
anyway that brings us to the end of
another video
what do you think could credence's
phoenix be albus's beloved and faithful
forks or is it just another one of
grindelwald's elaborate illusions let me
know your thoughts in the comments below
and as always if you enjoyed this video
don't forget to like it and subscribe to
the channel
until next time
memory is everything
you